Найбільша техногенна катастрофа у Європі за останні десятиліття.
Так офіційний Київ називає знищення Каховської ГЕС.
Якими будуть наслідки - військові, гуманітарні, екологічні - далі у поясненні DW.
80 населених пунктів опинилися в зоні підтоплення.
Це 17 тисяч людей на правобережжі, яке контролює Україна.
10 сіл і частина Херсона опинилися у воді.
Люди втратили житло, а для багатьох тварин вода стала смертельною пасткою.
Усе сиділа, усе сподівалася, що залишимося.
А потім як почала бігти вода, з такою силою, що…
Росіяни, мабуть, підбили дамбу не подумавши, як-то кажуть.
Вони негуманні. Їм нема пробачення, ніяк, абсолютно…
Лівий берег Дніпра, окупований росіянами, географічно нижчий.
Там наслідки значно масштабніші.
Попри це, як заявив президент Зеленський,
російські окупанти "повністю провалили" евакуацію людей звідти.
У містах, які брали воду з Каховського водосховища, ситуація теж складна.
Зокрема, Кривий Ріг і окупований Бердянськ втратили основне джерело води.
Доля криворізьких промислових підприємств, а також заводів у Нікополі, Марганці й Покрові
- під питанням, адже виробництво теж залежить від води.
Найбільшого удару зазнало сільське господарство.
Надто - овочівництво.
Зрошення земель на півдні залежало від Каховського водосховища.
Тепер воно неможливе.
Після повені тисячі людей одразу стали біженцями.
Згодом, через втрату роботи в промисловості і сільському господарстві,
ще більше мешканців півдня України можуть залишити регіон.
Якими будуть наслідки для тимчасово окупованого Росією Криму
- прогнозувати складно. Кримський канал брав воду з Каховського водосховища.
Офіційний Київ застерігає, що півострів може залишитися без води на роки.
Так звана окупаційна адміністрація заявляє,
що водосховища на півострові заповнені більше, ніж зазвичай,
і питної води людям не бракує, принаймні поки що.
Запорізька атомна електростанція, яка перебуває в окупації,
потребує води з Каховського водосховища для охолодження.
Нині ставок-охолоджувач АЕС заповнений, але він поступово випаровується.
Наразі у МАГАТЕ певні, що безпосередньої загрози для ЗАЕС поки немає.
Є низка альтернативних джерел води.
Основний - це великий охолоджувальний ставок біля майданчика,
розташований вище за рівень водосховища.
Оскільки реактори не працювали певний час,
води для охолодження з цього ставка може вистачити на кілька місяців.
В українському "Енергоатомі" кажуть, що наповнити резервуар-охолоджувач можна,
зокрема, з підземних свердловин.
Екологічні наслідки катастрофи на Каховській ГЕС в Офісі президента прирівнюють до застосування зброї масового знищення.
Понад 150 тисяч тон машинного масла потрапили в Дніпро.
Витік може бути ще більшим.
До того ж, через підтоплення у воді опиняються сміттєзвалища, кладовища, промислові відходи.
Екосистема, яка склалася в дельті Дніпра за 70 років існування Каховського водосховища, назавжди зруйнована.
Ми втратили національний природний парк "Нижньодніпровський",
частини Смарагдової мережі природоохоронних територій європейського значення.
Я розумію, що певні ділянки дикої природи ми втратили назавжди.
Крім того, невідомо, як виглядатиме русло Дніпра надалі, коли вода спаде.
Експерти кажуть, що південь України може перетворитися на пустелю.
У ГУР припускають, що російські війська підірвали греблю Каховської ГЕС,
щоб зупинити контрнаступ ЗСУ.
Водночас у міноборони кажуть, що катастрофа не вплине на їхні плани.
Західні експерти розглядають різні сценарії.
Якщо українці розглядали можливість наступу через Дніпро в Херсонській області, то так.
Але в іншому випадку це анітрохи не завадить наступу.
Майбутній наступ, схоже, буде зосереджений на Донеччині й Запоріжжі.
Наразі ми бачимо пробні атаки з метою перевірити російську оборону.
Це призведе до припинення постачання прісної води до Криму,
що, з одного боку, ускладнить роботу російської влади.
З іншого боку, це зруйнує електропостачання, створить гуманітарну катастрофу,
тому виникне необхідність у переселенні людей.
А оскільки територія контролюється Росією, це відволіче російських силовиків
і, можливо, змусить РФ перекинути сили в Нову Каховку, щоб упоратися з цим.
Вище по Дніпру, коли вода піде на спад, зокрема там,
де донедавна було водосховище, рівень води буде нижчим.
Можливо, протягом літа ці землі підсохнуть.
Складно прогнозувати зміни на полі бою.
Тож, ми можемо говорити лише в загальних термінах.
Але ми знаємо, що українська армія краще пристосовується до змін, ніж російська.
Водночас Володимир Зеленський заявив:
руйнування росіянами джерела води для Криму означає,
що вони усвідомили необхідність втечі з півострова.
Про можливість відновлення Каховської ГЕС і водосховища
можна буде говорити лише після звільнення цих територій.